I think food has always been a very big part of my family
with my grandfather working in the food industry,
although I never saw my grandfather cook.
My grandmother did all the cooking at home
and he was definitely more in the management side.
And I think that's where the employment ideals came from.
But my mom, her love language is cooking.
And so she taught me to cook.
And we talk about this with our apprentices as well.
Cooking is actually a financial skill
because if you don't know how to cook for yourself,
eating out is very expensive, it's not as healthy.
And so that was just kind of ingrained into me
that we cook to be together, we cook for our health,
we cook because that's part of life.
So I think it just, I think it brought my family
closer to what I was doing, but it just was a good fit.
I think I was always very into cooking
and being in the kitchen and nourishing my family.
I had one child when I started this job, I now have three.
So yeah, food is a big part of our life.